We appreciate the support of our sponsors to find out how you can be part of the
next, what if disgust contact sales at notorious dot LLC.
Energy drinks have a spectrum. There's this stereotypical energy drink.
The one that people usually think of, which is high caffeine, high sugar,
and then there's the other end of the spectrum, which is green P E vitamins,
natural sweetener. And that's it.
So it's very difficult to say all energy drinks are healthy or unhealthy.
You have to look at the specific ingredients and the caffeine.
Peter.
My name is Richard Garner and I am an energy drink
alcoholic.
I was the youth always start off the show very dramatically with something like
that. I wasn't sure, uh, what was going to happen today,
but apparently today we're in the middle of an intervention is that I'm only
half kidding. I mean,
and I certainly don't want it to seem like I'm making light of the 12 step
program work, where people in a real, uh, you know, AA meetings,
whatever it, because the truth of the matter is by all definitions,
I would be considered addicted to energy drinks.
My day starts like starts when you say starts means like wake
up and like, I have literally crack a,
a monster red bull whatever's really on sale, to be honest.
Like there's no difference in taste two. There is, there is a different a taste,
but it tells you, it's not about the taste at the end. It's about this,
about the getting Jack does that, what were you saying? Well, it's about,
it's about yes, but waking up, I would say that is out of the ordinary.
And from all I've heard about energy drinks is a,
I've never had one myself. Wow. For years and years,
and years or cease to amaze, you had a single one you're waking, wake and bake.
Basically quick bake is a whole other show by the way.
But I would say if I was saying, I, I woke up and had a coffee right away,
you wouldn't think that's crazy. I wouldn't.
And I know what you're getting at because coffee is caffeine is a drug and
that's obviously, uh, you know, not necessarily good for you either,
but it's just a widely accepted coffee, tea, even beer and spirits.
It is. And we live in a world where again, it's,
it's not always just because it's legal, that it's right,
or just not a lot of people have studied this,
but thankfully our guest today has studied this because this is an area
that I think is just emerging as something we need to understand more about, uh,
whether it's fatigue,
whether it's how people sort of manage stimulating themselves,
whether they should be at all. But that is why we were welcoming today.
Danielle Robertson, wrath, caffeine, scientist, author speaker,
and really one of the only people I know that studied this area as much as
pretty much anybody out there,
the author of are you a monster or a rockstar?
Danielle Robertson, wrath. Welcome to what if discussed?
Thank you so much for having me.
So, I mean, I guess it's a,
it's a fair question off the top because I think most people like Peter,
they default to energy drinks are bad. Yeah.
And most of the studies or articles you read, reflect that.
So they, they, they, but they usually are sort of combined with,
you know, if you're having six or seven a day or so,
let's just get started on that. Um, first question,
where do you fall on whether they're sort of healthy or not healthy energy
drinks?
Well, that is a very tricky question.
It's tricky to say energy drinks are healthy or they're unhealthy for the same
reason.
It's tricky to say cereal is healthy or unhealthy on one side of the spectrum,
you have lucky charms on the other side of the spectrum,
you have raising brands.
And so energy drinks have a similar spectrum.
There's this stereotypical energy drink. The one that people usually think of,
which is high caffeine, high sugar.
And then there's the other end of the spectrum, which is green tea, B vitamins,
natural sweetener. And that's it.
So it's very difficult to say all energy drinks are healthy or unhealthy.
You have to look at the specific ingredients and the caffeine content.
So as Richard, so helpfully pointed out off the top of caffeine, uh,
from coffee, maybe, uh, just as bad, but, uh, you know,
you mentioned green tea as being a good one. That's full of caffeine as well.
And coffee is the drink of choice for most people that I know at least on this
continent. Um, how did the two stack up energy drinks and coffee?
Well, there's a lot of differences,
which we probably don't have time to get into here,
but there's three key differences between coffee and energy drinks.
The first is that the caffeine content, isn't what you'd expect.
People that love their coffee sometimes look down on or worry
about people that have their energy drinks,
but a Grundy brew coffee from Starbucks is equal to
three red bulls grenade.
Coffee is the caffeine content of three red bulls. I'll give you another one.
One grand,
a pumpkin spice latte is about one can of monster energy
or one and a half red bowls.
So you really have to look at the caffeine content and not be focused on,
is it a coffee with a healthy halo or an energy drink with its negative
stereotypes? So that's the first difference the caffeine content.
The other thing is that energy drinks are really good about telling you how much
caffeine is in the container. That's part of their best practices.
It's really hard to know how much caffeine you're getting with coffee,
because it's a natural product. They don't have to label the amount of caffeine.
So it's very difficult to know how much caffeine you're getting.
And then the third key difference between coffee and energy drinks is what other
people are in that party. It's called the food matrix. So with coffee,
you're just getting caffeine and water and antioxidants with energy
drinks, you might be getting tarring B vitamins, glucuronolactone,
other ingredients. So you have to look at the whole picture.
You have to look at the whole food matrix and coffee because it's simpler
is often, but not always healthier because there's fewer things.
But if you're adding cream and sugar, that might not be true.
You have to look at every, every piece of the puzzle.
Well like most things on the show or otherwise a little more complex than
initially thought,
we're going to continue with Danielle Robertson wrath, uh,
after the break more on what if discussed?
What if disgust is brought to you today by keeps, you know, as guys,
so much of our identity is wrapped up in our hair.
That's why as we get a little older and start noticing the first signs of hair
loss,
it definitely feels like panic time facing no guy is ever ready to go bald.
So thankfully there's now there's keeps the simple and easy way to keep your
hair.
Yeah, the numbers are actually a little more startling than we might think.
Two out of three guys experienced some sort of male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 Pete.
So it's something you have to get on while you still have the hair.
Well, you can get treated from home.
You used to have to go to the doctor's office for your hair loss prescription,
but now thanks to keeps. You can visit a doctor online and get hair loss,
medication delivered right to your home.
They deliver your medication every three months.
So you can say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines and awkward doctor visits.
And it is a long process,
four to six months before you really start seeing the results.
But there's plenty of testimonials of people that are super happy with that and
are happy. They did it,
but you've got to get started because the sooner you start,
the more hair you keep for lack of a better.
No, I love that. If you're ready to take action and prevent hair loss,
go to keeps.com/what if to receive your first month of treatment for free
that's K E E P s.com/what F.
Welcome back to what if discussed. We are with Danielle Robertson, wrath,
the author of, are you a monster or are you a rock star?
Is that right? Is that, did I get the title right? Daniel?
Yes. Yes. Are you a monster or a rockstar guide to energy drinks?
And so it is a title by the way, it is.
Title, but it's also a helpful book in,
in that this is an area that a lot of people don't really understand.
There is information out there. There's not tons of studies. Uh,
there's articles. You, you know, you talked off the top of,
most of them skew towards, they're not good,
but not surprisingly most articles about coffee skew towards that's good.
And we talked with Danielle in the first part of the show about, well,
some of that's also misleading more on that,
um, in the end, their, their delivery systems, right? I mean,
that's the one thing we haven't really talked about. It's whether it's coffee,
whether it's caffeine pills, uh, whether it's energy drinks,
these are systems that are designed to sort of deliver caffeine. Um,
does the science in the end support long-term moderated
caffeine use as healthy?
Yes. Yes, it does. In fact, there was a giant,
giant research paper. I mean, 50 bases,
a systematic review published in 2017 in the journal of food,
chemistry, and toxicology.
And they looked at decades worth of research on caffeine from
all different sources, coffee, tea, energy, drinks, food with caffeine.
They concluded what papers before them have concluded that if you stay
under 400 milligrams of caffeine per day,
then there's no increased risks for things like
cardiovascular effects, behavioral effects, reproductive effects,
or developmental effects. So that 400 milligrams is like the,
what do you call it? The pivot point on a Seesaw.
If you say below that the benefits of caffeine outweigh the side
effects.
If you go over 400 milligrams of caffeine and you start having more side effects
than benefits.
Interesting. Now,
th this is ultimately probably more of a conversation about energy,
specifically stimulation is we're, we're all looking for stimulation.
And you know, this may come under the category of that's a story for another.
What if, but give us a, give us a picture about, uh,
the epidemic of fatigue.
What's what is your research told you about why we're so tired all the time?
Well, there's two major causes of this increase in fatigue.
The first one is our screens. We're looking at our screens all the time,
so that is messing up our circadian rhythm. That's the biggest,
the biggest reason.
But the second reason is that as more and more products come out in the
marketplace with caffeine people aren't drinking,
or aren't consuming caffeine as strategically as they can. For example,
we've been drinking coffee forever.
So the average person knows that coffee is good.
They know they drink it in the morning, it's fine,
but they might not be thinking about how that cup of coffee is sabotaging their
sleep. And so they drink caffeine at 3:00 PM. They don't sleep well.
They wake up tired, they need more caffeine. And it just it's a vicious cycle.
So I believe that that is what's happening. And in fact, um,
in Michael Poland's books, caffeine,
he makes the same exact mistake that a rookie might make.
He goes from having no caffeine whatsoever to having this very strong coffee,
with extra shots of espresso,
that's equivalent to not working out for three years and then signing up for,
or for a marathon.
Like you need to be more strategic with how much caffeine you have,
how quickly you drink it and what time of day you're drinking it.
And I don't think enough people are doing that, which is why I do what I do.
I enjoy a nice espresso after supper.
I know espresso's got a little bit of less caffeine in it,
but is that ill-advised like you're saying after 3:00 PM,
I heard you say is that, is that sort of the cutoff time for drinking caffeine?
That's what I recommend. Assuming that you have a normal schedule,
you're not working night shift or anything,
assuming that you go to bed around 10:00 PM or midnight,
you want to cut yourself off from caffeine around three,
because it takes three to six hours for half of that caffeine to leave your
system.
So you want to give that caffeine enough time to be metabolized before you try
and go to sleep.
And 3:00 PM is a good cutoff point for caffeine to leave your system.
Well,
a lot more to talk about a lot more to dive into pros and cons of energy
drinks and caffeine use, uh, the management of it. Also,
I'd like to get into a little more about the brands themselves, you know,
which ones are quote, unquote, better, healthier if any of them are, um,
Danielle, can you stick around for a little more?
So.
We are going to continue with Danielle Robertson, wrath talking, caffeine,
talking energy drinks. Um, but, uh, for the,
we'll talk a little bit about sugar too, and yeah, the, which is actually a big,
you know, sugar free or not sugar is also a big part of this is a good point.
Uh, but for the YouTube viewers, uh, where can they go? Well,
if you're watching us on YouTube right now, there's a link right below.
You can see you click on that and you can, uh,
get the extended audio podcasts where we'll have more with caffeine,
scientist and author, Daniel Robertson, wrath.
If you're listening already on the podcast, there's nothing for you to do,
just stay tuned. Um, and you'll hear the rest of us, but if you are leaving,
thanks for joining us and we'll see you next week on what if discussion.
[Inaudible].